welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and today our
guest is Professor Alex stone sweet the
lightener professor of law politics and
international studies professor stone
suites interests are comparative and
international politics and law and
European integration his research
focuses on how rural systems emerge and
evolve over time and with what
consequences for society most of his
published work approaches this question
by looking at how new legal systems
develop today we'll be talking about his
newest book called a Europe of Rights
the impact of European Convention on
Human Rights on national legal systems
welcome professor stone sweet thank you
most of your research focuses on new
legal systems and how they evolve why
are you interested in that well my work
is a little bit peculiar and in that
most legal scholars the most political
scientists study full-blown legal
systems or legal systems that have
already matured and are already
functioning usually in a successful way
and i'm interested in brand new legal
systems because we don't know if they're
going to be the successes or failures
and because when people build new legal
systems their constituting new political
communities or new systems of governance
and when older pre-existing political
communities redesign their legal systems
get new constitutions or set up new
court systems they're redefining who
they are politically and as a community
so I'm interested in and what are the
what are the basis for when legal
systems will be successful and when
they'll be when they'll fail and what
their functions are and it turns out
that legal systems and judges and courts
in particular are critical to how human
committees are able to reproduce
themselves over time how how societies
are able to integrate over time and
circumstances change how economies are
able to grow and integrate so for the
last 10 years or 12 years now I've been
working a lot on the year
European integration and showing how
important it has been for the important
it has been for integration particularly
social and economic integration how
people interact across borders in Europe
how important the legal system has been
for the success of that project on the
contrary in places like Africa and in
Latin America integration projects
haven't worked and that's partly because
the legal systems have been so
ineffective so what new legal systems
are you most interested in today right
now I'm developing a project on private
transnational governance and I'm
interested in how multinational
corporations and their lawyers are
building a new a new legal system but a
private legal system that doesn't rely
on the state to manage their commercial
relationships so almost all contracts
now be well when Nike has to make tennis
shoes in Malaysia or Vietnam they have
to have a contract with somebody that
their that they're that it's going to
make those shoes in those countries and
most of these kinds of contracts now
specify arbitration to deal with
contractual disputes rather than court
systems and so through these arbitration
clauses in contracts private companies
are building a kind of private court
system for transnational Commerce and I
find that fascinating because it once
again it allows us to look at the
dynamics of how new legal systems are
new court systems evolved furthermore in
contracting in when multinational
corporations and their lawyers build new
contracts often today because they're
put put under pressure from NGOs and
interest groups that are interested in
environmental protection or in human
rights human rights records they want
these corporations to put directly into
the contracts human rights standards
workplace conditions environmental
protection standards and so on and we
find that corporations are doing this
more and more which then raises the
question of how these standards how
these codes of conduct which are again
are purely private they're not
obligatory are nonetheless being
monitored and enforced and then
companies have multiple ways of
monitoring and forcing them they can do
it themselves they can hire an
accounting firm like
Cooper lie brand or these Anderson is
huge accounting firms who used to just
used to just audit the contract from its
financial you know from its financial
aspects and nowadays they do what's
called social accounting they look and
or environmental accounting and they
look to see how the contractual
relationship is doing is faring on the
human right side or on the Environmental
Protection side or a third way that they
can do it which is my preferred way is
that they can ask a third party a
neutral third party to go and go
directly to say Vietnam or Malaysia and
look and see how the workplace is
actually being managed and then certify
that workplace and the most and the most
important or one of the most interesting
organization does this is called social
accounting international it's and it's
funded by labor and by corporations
themselves and by NGOs and interest
groups for interests in human rights and
environmental protection and so I find
this fascinating because it's a it's a
kind of a transnational legal system
that's purely private it doesn't rely on
the state but it is increasingly
important for managing global global
economic activity so tell us about your
new book and what is the European
Convention well the European Convention
on Human Rights was signed by 10 states
in 1953 and entered into force in 1953
today it covers a 47 countries in Europe
and 850 million people so it's the it's
also the most active and most effective
international human rights regime in the
world last year it received 50,000 more
than 50,000 petitions from individuals
directly to it and it issued more than
1,500 rulings it's the most single most
active court in the world to give you to
give you compare comparison the Supreme
Court the United States issues fewer
than 100 rulings per year this court
this transnational court made up of 47
judges from 47 different countries
issues issues 1500 + decisions a year on
the merits wow that's fascinating that's
quite a bit of research to follow I
would imagine yes the new book with the
new book traces it attempts to trace the
impact
of the European Convention on Human
Rights and how its interpreted by the
European Court of Human Rights on the
member states themselves on the nation
states themselves contracting states so
instead of a focus where we look just at
the European Court of Human Rights and
what it does and how it interprets
rights we care about how legislators and
governments administrators and judges
receive or adapt to or coordinate their
activities their decision-making to the
to the rights that are in the convention
as their interpreted over time by the
European Convention human right now the
convention completely changed in 1998
when the state's decided to make the
jurisdiction of the European Court
compulsory by that it means that by that
means that states can't block
applications that come from their own
citizens to the court against them from
going to court and they also made a
right of all citizens are from that
matter all inhabitants of the convention
territory that is all 47 countries they
gave an absolute right to individuals to
petition directly the court when they
believe that their rights have been
violated after remedies have been
exhausted in those countries so in 1998
then the court really became a kind of
transnational constitutional court for
human rights in in the convention okay
so how much impact has the European
Convention on Human Rights actually had
on national political and legal systems
well in the last 20 years and
particularly and this is accelerated in
the last decades especially since the
changes in 1998 that I just mentioned
the courts impact has become really
profound across across all of the
contracting states of course some states
have been influenced more than others
those states that have very very very
good Human Rights records with good
systems of constitutional justice with
constitutional courts that protect
rights fairly comprehensively in the
national legal order such as Germany and
Ireland and Spain they haven't been
impacted as much the convention doesn't
fill those gaps but in other systems
where they don't have they don't have a
bill of rights in their content
most most countries actually in the old
Western Europe didn't have bill of
rights in their in their countries
countries and I didn't have judicial
review is they didn't have judges didn't
have the power of striking down or
annulling as unconstitutional statutes
that emanated out of the Parliament
Parliament swear sovereign Parliament's
were or supreme and the acts that they
produce legislation statutes were
supreme in the legal order in those
systems has been profound change because
the convention now functions as a kind
of surrogate Bill of Rights it becomes
the Bill of Rights and to the extent to
which judges can directly enforce them
is extent to which the convention starts
to have direct effect in the legal
system in most systems now since 1998 in
most systems there's only a couple of
exceptions the in convention has been
incorporated into the national legal
system at a level that's above statutes
above legislation but below that of the
Constitution what that means is that
individuals can plead rights from the
convention directly in national courts
against their own national government
and judges are expected to enforce them
even against statutes so again what this
means is that the way that the
convention has developed and the way
that the the way that the convention has
been incorporated into national law that
is with that super legislative status
means that means that the convention
functions as a kind of constitutional
bill of rights for all those states that
didn't have it before so your book shows
that the convention system is presently
at a critical juncture what are the
major challenges facing the European
Court on human rights today well in 1990
the convention system added 24 new
states with 450 million people this is
called Eastern enlargement this happened
after the fall of the Berlin well in the
end of the disintegration of the Soviet
bloc all of those countries east of
western europe east of the european
community and the european union drafted
new constitutions were engaged in
democratization efforts and the Council
of Europe which is which I which the
convention is a part decided the
political bodies state
in the Council of Europe the Western
European states decided that it was
important to bring the Eastern Europe
into the Western European into the
convention system in order to bolster
democratization efforts in order to give
them to to provide a bulwark for for
these new systems so that they wouldn't
slide back into authoritarianism and so
on and one of the problems has been at
some of these states we're not really
ready to be brought into this new system
and this is certainly this case of the
Ukraine Georgia Russia Turkey Romania
Bulgaria today more than half of all of
the 50,000 petitions that come in each
year come from only four states Romania
Ukraine Russia and Turkey in these
places you have massive human rights
failures of a systemic kind you have
judges who are underpaid or corrupt you
have judges who are afraid of political
reprisals if they do their job correctly
you have governments who actually censor
the mail and if they see mail you could
I should sit back up individuals can
apply directly to the conventions
through a letter basically it's
incredibly simple in costless to
register one of these complaints and
some governments including Russia have
actually stopped mail going out of
Russia to the Strasbourg Court to the
European Court of Human Rights because
they don't want the European Court to
handle some of these kinds of complaints
and a further problem is as you as you
know if you've been watching the news
Russia's is russia for instance is
engaged in some is engaged in in virtual
civil war in chechnya and it's and it's
been engaged in in some military action
in georgia all of those all of those
actions will will generate many plant
complaints and petitions they'll all
come to the court and unlike the
American Supreme Court which has a
political questions doctrine and has a
set of other doctrines a different that
says that when we're dealing with
foreign policy and war issues think of
Guantanamo we defer to our president we
don't we don't really want to apply the
same standards that we might apply to
government action within America to what
the government does outside of America
the European Court of Human Rights
does that there is no political question
every question needs to according to the
court every question needs to be
examined and dealt with on its on its
merits according to the according to the
law and according to the convention and
that means that no matter how political
and how controversial question is that
comes up in any of these 47 states the
court is almost four certainly to get it
at the same time the court knows that
when it's dealing with some of these
cases some of these difficult cases of
countries that are unable to protect
human rights on their own through their
own domestic processes their own
domestic institutions they know that
that there a capacity to actually impact
on them is quite low so the court can
continually handle hundreds and hundreds
sometimes thousands of the same kinds of
complaints and give direction to the
Russian authorities or the Ukrainian
stories of how they need to change their
system in order to stop generating these
kinds of complaints but they also can
know that that the Russians of the
Ukraine's are unlikely to succeed at
reforming their own institutions thank
you for sharing some of your work with
us today for more information on
professor stone sweet his research and
of course his newest book please visit
our website at yale edu backslash
macmillan report be sure to join us
again for another episode of the
macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale thank you so much